now we're not calling anybody a white  supremacist here  but you have to ask yourself i want to  put this on the screen now  what is this this symbol of hate  symbol of hate posing as a cookie jar  this is painfully dumb  doing in don lamont's kitchen do you see  that  that right there ladies and gentlemen is  a white supremacist  q supremacist went on cookie jar  now we're not calling for the department  of justice to look more deeply into this  because that's not our place  we're a cable news show not a law  enforcement agency  but let's just put it this way if you  find yourself with a blackface cookie  jar  in your own kitchen  it's time to reflect that means you  don lemon